drama drama drama phil mickelson bryson  deshambo and nine others filed an  anti-trust lawsuit against the pga tour  they're fighting the tour's decision to  suspend them because they participated  in the liv events the motion says that  the tour's conduct causes harm to the  players and shuts down their opportunity  to participate in quote the first  meaningful competitive threat that torah  has faced in decades the pga tour says  it welcomes healthy competition  but it says the saudi arabia-backed liv  tour is not supporting the growth of the  game toxic also three out of the 11  players have requested a restraining  order to allow them to compete in the  fedex cup playoffs next week